>> Tucker: YOU MIGHT HAVE MIXED
FEELINGS ABOUT MILO
YIANNOPOULOS.
IF YOU'RE ON THE LEFT, YOU
REALLY HATED HIM.
IF YOU NEVER HATED ANYBODY FOR
SOME REASON AS MUCH AS MILO
YIANNOPOULOS.
MILO YIANNOPOULOS CAN'T EVEN GO
TO A BAR WOULDN'T GETTING DRIVEN
OUT BY SCREAMING PEOPLE.
A CROWD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF
AMERICA, MOST OF THEM RICH KIDS,
GATHERED AROUND HIM TO CHANT
NAZI SCUM, GET OUT.
WATCH.
[CHANTING].
>> Tucker: WONDER HOW MANY OF
THOSE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS HAVE
THEIR OWN STUDENT LOANS?
PROBABLY NONE.
THAT'S MY GUESS.
THEY CLAIM THAT THE NAZI LABEL
IS JUSTIFIED BY SOME OF MILO'S
SUPPORTERS ONCE MADE A NAZI
SALUTE.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT MILO SAW
THEM DO IT.
WHATEVER.
THE MOB INCLUDED AN EDITOR AT
THE NATION MAGAZINE CALLED
"ANTI-SHIELDS" AND A GIZMOTO
WROTER AND IN BRENDAN O'CONNOR.
WE ASKED THEM TO COME ON THE
SHOW.
THEY SENT US THIS STATEMENT
WHICH THEY REPEATED ON THE
PHONE, GO F YOURSELVES.
WE HAVE CHAD HERE WITH US WHO
WAS AT THE BAR WITH MILO.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THIS TOOK PLACE -- AM I GETTING
THIS WRONG?
THIS WAS A RESTAURANT CALLED
CHURCHILL'S ON PARK AVENUE IN
NEW YORK.
IT HAD $16 SALMON APPETIZERS AND
THIS WAS THE VENUE THAT THE
SOCIALISTS CHOOSE MEET AT?
A RESTAURANT NAMED CHURCHILL'S?
>> AND YOU NOTICE THE NATIONALIC
FLAGS HANGING AROUND.
THEY MUST HAVE COME FOR THE
CRAFT BEER IS WHAT I CONCLUDED.
SURELY WE THOUGHT THIS PLACE
WOULD BE SAFE.
WE MADE RESERVATIONS.
WE JUST WANTED A SIMPLE SUNDAY
ROAST.
WE WERE LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS.
HE'S BRITISH.
PROBABLY HASN'T HAD A GOOD ROAST
IN A LONG TIME.
WE ENCOUNTERED OF ALL THE GIN
JOINTS IN THE WORLD, WE HAD TO
WALK IN WHERE THE SOCIALISTS
WERE MEETING.
>> Tucker: SO THEY STARTED
SCREAMING AT YOU AND WHAT
HAPPENED?
>> WE STEPPED OUTSIDE FOR A
MOMENT.
ON THE WAY BACK IN, THEY WERE
SHOUTING.
THEY WOULD NOT LET US GO BACK TO
OUR TABLE.
WE FIGURED -- WE WERE GOING TO
GET OUR BAGS AND LEAVE OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THE STAFF AND THE
OTHER CUSTOMERS.
OTHER CUSTOMERS WERE SCARED AND
RUNNING OUT WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
SO WHEN WE TRIED TO GO BACK TO
OUR TABLE, THEY GATHERED AROUND
HIM AND WOULDN'T LET US DO BACK.
A VERY LARGE -- I THINK A WOMAN,
LOOKED LIKE A WOMAN, SHOVED
MILO.
THAT'S WHEN WE REALIZED THIS WAS
GOING TO GET VIOLENT.
IT WAS THE TWO OF US.
WE ASKED THE STAFF IF THEY WOULD
RETRIEVE OUR BAGS.
THEY DID VERY POLITELY AND MILO
JUST SAID I WAS A VERY BIG TRUMP
SUPPORTER AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT.
THE WAITRESS WAS VERY CONFUSED
AND SAID OKAY.
CLEARLY THE STAFF OR THE PATRONS
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON OR
UNDERSTOOD THIS REACTION.
WE WERE TRY GUYS TRYING TO HAVE
A ROAST.
>> Tucker: DID YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THE MEETING WAS IN PROGRESS
WHEN YOU CHOSE THIS RESTAURANT?
>> NO.
I DIDN'T KNOW THEY KNEW WHERE
PARK AVENUE WAS.
THEIR PARENTS DO.
BUT WE MADE RESERVATIONS SEVERAL
DAYS IN ADVANCE.
WE JUST WANTED A ENGLISH ROAST.
THIS PLACE HAD COME VERY HIGHLY
RECOMMENDED.
THAT WAS THE END OF IT.
I SEE ON TWITTER -- BECAUSE THE
OPTICS OF THIS ARE SO TERRIBLE
AND THEY KNOW HOW AWFUL THEY
LOOK, ON TWITTER THEY SAID WE
PLANNED THIS.
CERTIFIED SALON REPORTERS, BUT
CHECK MARKS SAID MILO BROUGHT
HIS HUSBAND OUT THAT EVERYBODY
KNOWS MILO IS MARRIED TO A BLACK
GUY.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M A SEAN KING
OR WHAT.
BUT SO THEY KEEP TRYING TO SAY
WE DID THIS ON PURPOSE.
>> Tucker: SO THIS IS BRENDAN
O'CONNOR.
HE WORKED AT GIZMOTO.
THERE HE IS.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY ACTING ON BEHALF
OF THE GLOBAL PROLOTARIATE.
THIS IS THE KID THAT WAS ON
BEHALF OF THE SOCIALISTS.
WE CHECKED, NEEDLESS TO SAY FROM
ONE OF THE RICHEST SUBURBS OF
NEW JERSEY, WENT TO A $50,000 A
YEAR BOARDING SCHOOL.
WAS HE THE ONE SCREAMING AT YOU?
>> YEAH.
HE MARCHED OUTSIDE AND ASKED
MILO ABOUT 8-MONTH-OLD NEWS
STORIES.
MILO WAS VERY POLITE AND HE SAID
I'M HERE WITH MY FRIEND.
IF YOU WANT TO INTERVIEW ME,
SEND AN E-MAIL TO ME AND WE'LL
SET SOMETHING UP.
HE WOULDN'T DROP IT.
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
HE HAD NO IDEA WHAT TO ASK MILO.
FINALLY MILO SAID LEAVE ME
ALONE.
I'M HERE WITH MY FRIEND.
GET YOUR FACTS STRAIGHT.
I'LL GIVE YOU A PROPER
INTERVIEW.
THEN WE HAVE OF COURSE THIS
NATION EDITOR THAT ADMITTED ON
TWITTER SHE RUNS THE NATION'S
TWITTER HANDLE.
SHE --
>> Tucker: ANOTHER WORKER.
>> ANOTHER WORKER.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW, I DON'T
HAVE TO TELL YOU THIS, BUT THEY
WERE ALL WHITE.
ALL OF THEM.
SO SHE'S BEEN GOING ON A STORM
ON TWITTER STANDING UP FOR THE
WORKING CLASS AND THE PEOPLE AND
ALL OF THOSE PRECIOUS BLACK
PEOPLE --
>> Tucker: THERE WAS A TIME WHEN
SOCIALISTS CARED ABOUT ECONOMICS
AND HAD A CASE TO MAKE.
I DIDN'T AGREE WITH IT.
BUT THEY HAD A REASONED
THOUGHT-OUT CASE THAT WAS
FUNDAMENTAL.
RICH KIDS LIKE THIS GOT INVOLVED
AND IT BAKE ALL ABOUT RACE AND
GENDER LIKE EVERYTHING IS.
THANKS FOR JOINING US TONIGHT,
CHADWICK.
WE INVITED THIS BRENDAN O'CONNOR
KID ON AND WE HOPE HE WILL COME
ON FROM GIZMOTO.